[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIT GANDHI: Hi, my
name is Amit Gandhi.
And I'm a graduate
researcher at MIT.
Welcome to this course
on exploring fairness
in machine learning for
international development.
In this video, we
will examine bias
in machine learning models
through a pulmonary health
diagnostic case study.
In particular, we will
explore the influence
of representative data on
accuracy when building a model.
Pulmonary diseases, including
asthma COPD, allergic rhinitis,
and others, can have significant
detrimental health impacts
if undetected.
In remote areas with limited
access to health care,
they can often go
undiagnosed and untreated.
The motivation for this work
was to develop a screening
tool for community
health workers
to determine if patients
who were presenting symptoms
of pulmonary disease actually
have pulmonary disease.
To develop the tool,
data was collected
from 303 patients who
sought medical care
at health clinics between
2015 and 2018 in Kuna, India.
Patient data was collected
at health clinics
from two exams administered
by researchers--
a mobile health
diagnostic kit developed
by Dr. Fletcher's group
and a set of measurements
from a pulmonary
function test lab.
Health diagnoses were
performed by medical staff
with a focus on asthma,
allergic rhinitis, and COPD.
The overall disease
distribution among the patients
is shown in the plot.
The data included 175 patients
with pulmonary diseases
and 87 healthy patients.
Patients may also have
multiple pulmonary diseases--
for example, asthma and COPD.
The exploration of
representative sampling
on accuracy was conducted across
two protected variables, gender
and income.
The population distributions
for the two variables
can be seen in the slides.
For income
considerations, patients
were categorized as either
low income or high income.
The overall approach
to the bias study
was to divide the data set
into a larger training data
superset in a test data set.
A logistic regression model
with L2 regularization
was used to make
predictions on disease.
To train the model,
training data subsets
were randomly sampled
from the superset
that intentionally
introduce imbalances
along protected variables.
For example, with
regards to income,
training data subsets
ranged from 50 percent 50%
and 50% low income to 87.5% high
income and 12.5% low income.
To account for stochastic
error, this process
was run 1,000 times
for each test.
The area under the curve
of the receiver operating
characteristic curve was used as
a metric bracket for accuracy.
Starting with gender
bias analysis,
our training data sets and test
data set were divided as shown.
Male-female representativeness
was varied from 50-50
to 87.5 to 12.5.
The results for
predictive accuracy
for allergic rhinitis,
asthma, and COPD
are shown on the slide.
The data shows no significant
decrease in algorithm accuracy
as gender imbalances are
introduced in the data.
This may be
surprising considering
how we have highlighted the
principle of representativeness
in data throughout this course.
However, it is important to note
that protective variables do
not necessarily affect
outcome variables
and the lack of
representativeness
may not always introduce
bias or fairness into models.
Looking at our
results, we also notice
that our algorithm is more
accurate at predicting
COPD in women than men.
Exploring the
results further, we
look at other variables in
the correlation with gender.
In our data set, we found
that smoking heavily
correlated with gender.
55% of men reported that
they were nonsmokers
whereas 100% of women reported
that they were nonsmokers.
As a result, the
population of women
was more homogeneous, allowing
for higher predictive accuracy.
Moving on to the
income bias analysis,
the training data sets
and test data sets
were divided as shown.
Similar to the gender
study, representativeness
based on income was varied
for the training data set.
The results were
predictive accuracy
for allergic rhinitis,
asthma, and COPD
are shown on the slide.
Again, we see very little
difference in accuracy
as we change representativeness
within the sample.
COPD is the most sensitive
to socioeconomic status,
with a 4% difference in model
accuracy for high income
and low income populations.
Asthma and allergic
rhinitis show
no difference in performance.
In summary, we found
that representativeness
across the protected
variables of gendered income
do not play a large
role in model accuracy
for this example on
pulmonary diseases in India.
As part of building a
machine learning model,
it is always important to
check what effects, if any,
attentive attributes
may have on the model.
In the real world, it will be
impossible to find perfectly
balanced data sets.
And test such as
the one described
can be used to check for the
effect of representativeness
across protected variables
on data and model accuracy.
It is important to
understand these tradeoffs
so that you can make informed
decisions when building models.
Thank you for taking the time
to watch this case study.
And we hope that you'll
watch the other content
in the series.
[MUSIC PLAYING]